we're going to get to more on that in a
moment but first let's start with Manuel
bojorquez he is in Fort Myers Florida
that is about two hours south of where
we are at he's in an area also under
mandatory evacuation Manny what are you
seeing
well David good morning that calm before
the storm well it's over here as you can
see we're getting this constant pounding
rain and the winds are starting to pick
up but still preparation is the name of
the game Florida's division of Emergency
Management has already prepared more
than two million meals and has more than
a million gallons of water on hand to
help impacted areas after the storm and
as we await landfall here other parts of
the state are already seeing extreme
weather
Ian's outer bands spawned multiple
reported tornadoes across South Florida
Tuesday a preview of more dangerous
conditions to come
one reported tornado damaged several
planes at North Perry Airport in
Hollywood this is nuts
she is not happy in Key West powerful
wind snapped trees as heavy rains and
early storm surge triggered flash
flooding many people moved their cars to
Higher Ground in anticipation and
overnight Rising water began inundating
homes along the coast
earlier Tuesday hurricane Hunters flew
into the eye of the storm to collect
data and satellites captured this time
lapse of Ian churning and flashing with
lightning from space
[Music]
here on Earth NASA finished rolling its
Artemis rocket whose launch Ian delayed
back indoors ahead of the Hurricane's
arrival
in Tampa there was a steady flow of
traffic out of the city as people heeded
evacuation orders I've been here 45
years and this is the first time I left
for a storm and from the state's capital
Governor Ron DeSantis delivered this
warning late last night there will be a
catastrophic flooding and
life-threatening storm surge on the Gulf
Coast region time to evacuate is coming
to an end you need to evacuate now you
don't have to Traverse all across the
State of Florida you need to get to
Higher Ground you need to get to
structures that are safe
another major concern of course are
widespread power outages the governor
said 30 thousand utility workers are on
call ready to assist with restoration
efforts after the storm and Beyond
Florida Georgia has already declared a
state of emergency preparing for extreme
weather as Ian heads North but again
rain and wind picking up here conditions
only expected to get worse David
Manny bojorkquez Fort Myers Florida
thank you Manny